the last 24 hours have seen both reports
that Trump is imminently going to get
indicted and subsequently arrested by
the justice department federal charges
and the last 24 hours saw denials from
Donald Trump even when some of these
reports came from Trump's own social
media site truth social truth essential
let's discuss a um an article on just
the news which is sort of a wacky
right-wing website feds inform Trump he
is Target likely to be indicted as doj
rebuffs prosecutorial misconduct claim
Trump defense has submitted secret
evidence alleging a prosecutor tried to
sway witness testimony by discussing
Federal judgeship also published to
truth social this message breaking feds
informed Trump of imminent indictment by
special counsel Jack Smith however Trump
denying the report from his own website
posting quote no one has told me I'm
being indicted and I shouldn't be
because I've done nothing wrong but I
have assumed for years that I am a
capital T Target of the weaponized doj
and FBI starting with the russia-russia
Russia Hoak the no collusion Mueller
report impeachment hoax number one
impeachment hoax number two the perfect
Ukraine phone call and various other
scams and witch hunts a travesty of
justice and election interference at a
level never seen before republicans in
Congress must make this their number one
issue so is it true that Trump is
imminently going to be indicted and
arrested federally and charged these
would be the second charges against
Trump we may then see additional federal
charges we may then see charges at the
state level out of Georgia sometime
between July and September or is it all
wrong my bottom line on this is that it
does increasingly seem like yes Donald
Trump is going to be indicted federally
however he may not have been informed of
it over the last 24 to 48 hours the way
that just the news reported uh other
reports claim that maybe by the end of
tomorrow the doj will be requesting
those indictments from the grand jury
that is reconvened it's just important
to remember
when the indictments are asked for to
the grand jury
and then when the grand jury votes
potentially yes to do the indictments
and then when the indictment actually
happens these are three different things
and so like with many of these news
events that are quickly taking shape and
changing and whatever the case may be
you have to remember that sometimes
people are just confused about which
step of the process they're referring to
but at this point my guess my prediction
and I'm not in the prediction game but
my prediction if you don't make me Bet
On It is that yes Donald Trump is going
to be indicted federally and it seemed
to send him into an absolute and total
panic let's talk about that next if you
or one of your parents is starting to
lose your hearing you're not alone about
48 million Americans have hearing loss
and only one in five people who would
benefit from using a hearing aid are
actually using one our sponsors MD
hearing create FDA registered
rechargeable hearing aids that cost a
fraction of what you typically pay for
example MD hearings new Neo model car
less than 10 percent of what those
marked up hearing aids are being sold
for at most hearing clinics and the Neo
is MD hearings smallest hearing aid ever
no one will even know that it's there I
have a close family friend who uses MD
hearing and loves it she said it
performs better than any hearing aid
that she's used and it's far less
noticeable MD hearing even offers a
45-day risk-free trial with a 100
percent money back guarantee so you can
buy with confidence and they have a
special deal for my audience when you
buy a pair of hearing aids you'll get
them for just 149.99 each plus they'll
include a free extra charging case go to
mdhearing.com and use the code Pacman
the link is down below